a nuclear disaster at the zaparesia
plant have regularly surfaced as
fighting flared in and around it since
the start of the war
Kiev says Russian forces could now be
planning a so-called false flag
operation setting off explosives on the
roof of the plant to make it look like
Ukrainian forces are attacking it
we have information from our
intelligence that on the roof of several
power units of the zabarucho nuclear
power plant the Russian military
installed objects similar to explosives
perhaps to simulate the head on the
plane maybe they have some other
scenarios
for its part Moscow has accused the
ukrainians of planning to attack the
plant with long-range Precision weapons
the situation at the plant is quite
tense because the threat of sabotage by
the key regime is high and the
consequences will be catastrophic the
key regime has repeatedly demonstrated
its willingness to stoop to anything
both sides have drawn comparisons with
the recent destruction of the Kharkov Ka
Dam which caused extensive flooding and
which they blame each other for
Moscow says the destruction of the dam
shows what Kiev is capable of Ukrainian
President Vladimir zelenski says the
failure of the International Community
to punish Russia for destroying the dam
has emboldened it now to attack the
nuclear plant Ukraine's Ministry of
Health has warned people living near the
plant to prepare to evacuate the area in
case of a major radiation leak
I have a small bag with clothes in case
I have to throw away the ones I'm
wearing and some medication and
documents with me as well as water and a
face mask that's it
I follow the news and of course I hope
that everything will turn out fine
nuclear energy is not a joke at all
we've already had this once before and
it's something that's frightful in
principle since the start of this war
people in the zapparesia region have
lived with the added fear of a nuclear
catastrophe but the precise nature of
these latest warnings seem to raise the
threat of a potential incident Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Kiev